we have another episode incoming of the
beginner to master
speedrun I am live streaming this on
Twitch uh twitch chat if you're watching
in real time feel free to say hi to the
Future YouTube audience if you're
watching in the future on YouTube don't
forget to follow on
Twitch don't forget to subscribe on
Twitch does help support the channel if
you have Amazon Prime you can subscribe
for free you can also interact with weeb
who spots a teddy bear yeah this is
going to be episode
12 and let's just hop into it I'm rated
911 playing Ivon
zelli and hopefully we'll have some
instructive
games okay Kings Pawn
opening I do have to sometimes be
careful like with stream snipers when I
live stream these speed runs but it'll
be okay uh this is a filor
defense which
is it's playable but it's slightly
passive because it blocks in the
bishop and I like this transformation
like after the pawn trade white has
pretty easy development with the rest of
the minor
pieces defend the E4 Pawn with the
Knight and there's a few different like
development setups to employ uh with the
Bishops like Bishop E3 and Bishop E2
would be very
solid H6 is a
sign this is a sign black was maybe
scared of Bishop
G5 but it is kind of a slow move I think
I'd rather
play a bit more actively here I'm going
to put the bishop on
C4 generally this is where you want your
Bishop in King's Pawn openings just
targeting
F7 I might have the choice like going
forward the next few
moves whether to Castle King side or
queen
side but King side's probably a bit more
[Music]
natural yeah let's Castle King
side so we can see black is bit more
passive like bit more restricted in
their
territory it's one benefit of having the
pawn more advanced or
on and generally in these sort of
[Music]
positions like I don't want to trade
unless there's a good reason for it like
if I play Knight takes C6 then black can
take
back and I just help black activate and
like breathe a bit more
easily so yeah I could consider Knight
F5 which allows Bishop takes but then
could open the E file
although I'm not sure how much I'm
getting there with Bishop
E7 there's another approach
here which like the more I'm looking at
it the
nicer it
looks I'm going to go for it is to play
Pawn E5 or Pawn F4 preparing some ideas
of Pawn E5 thank you emblem I appreciate
the
sub and there are cases where like
pushing the F Pawn early in the game can
be like really weakening but I think in
this case because I'm castled and I
really want to break in the center like
F4 is
Justified and we see Pawn
C5 which does attack the queen now it's
a question I could go back to E3 or
D3 if I move back to E3 it kind of
blocks a
bishop let's go back to D3
yeah and the drawback of playing C5 for
black is now this Pawn is what we can
call a backwards Pawn because it's on
the half openen file and it can't easily
move
forward because I'm just controlling D5
so many
times now I've noticed this a lot like
at especially at this rating level in
the
900s that players sometimes
will will just weaken their pawns and
then it can affect their position long
[Music]
term but in this position I think
there's a few issues for black like E5
is a move I really want to play
next and yeah if we calculate like Pawn
E5 let's say black takes I take back
then the f file opens and the knight's
going to be pinned to the F
Pawn and meanwhile I'll just go ahead
and play
E5 meanwhile if the Knight moves and I'm
ready to take the pawn on
D6 so I think like so far this is a nice
example of like how black playing a
little bit slowly in the opening can
really have major
consequences here it's still a question
like if I take with Rook then I get
Triple
forked Knight takes E5
taking with Bishop I think makes the
most
sense which then forces a
king to the f
file I'm very close to
checkmating we play Bishop
E6 attacking the king the bishop and the
Knight if a king goes back to E8 this is
Checkmate so no mercy that game
um doesn't always work out that
smoothly but in this case I think we saw
a nice example of just like developing
quickly playing
actively there might be a lot of players
who wouldn't play F4 like would maybe
focus on completing development which
would be a fine approach but sometimes
when you can expand especially when your
opponent is underdeveloped then it makes
some nice sense so that did feel like
the Blitz game I I played relatively
quickly that game but uh let's keep it
going let's move
on playing Sam
pry another player in the
900s okay so
here I'm debating what opening to
play I think I'll stick with um just a
standard attack
alion yeah white playing very normally
so
far H3 is a very safe move this um
prevents the Bishop from eventually
coming to
G4 I've had a lot of games in similar
types of
openings
that have featured like early blunders
for my opponents but here White's
playing like perfectly
fine and here I'm actually debating like
if I Castle then
D3 like maybe we can go into
that I can try and show how
to like fight for a win in a a
symmetrical
[Music]
position okay so yeah so with D3 white
is is preparing Bishop G5 and Knight D5
this is like one of the main
plans and there's a couple ways to deal
with it um first of all if I want I
could play
H6 which just prevents Bishop
G5 but there's another move here
which like I'm not sure if it's exact
Theory but I kind of like the nature of
it I'm going to start with Knight
A5 now this is a move like it's not
always that great
but in this case it's Justified because
I'm basically forcing the trade of
Knight for
Bishop oops remind me later all these
windows popping up have to update my
software um so yeah I just go ahead and
take the bishop and the other point of
like getting the Knight away from C6 is
now I have Pawn
C6 so now the Knight can no longer
access
D5
white very quickly playing B4 okay let's
take
this there's a question about earlier if
the E4 Pawn was
hanging it actually may have been yeah
maybe I should have addressed that but I
can share after the
game um okay I did take a hanging Pawn
so white has has given the first gift of
the
game
and now yeah now the pin isn't so
annoying
because white can't easily add another
attacker and trading only helps me
activate the
queen and now we have a spot where it's
two Bishops against two
knights and the two Bishops are already
like pretty well placed to try and
attack so I like the move here Queen G
B6 which just very simply aligns with a
king and a thr's bishop takes
H3 which my opponent does not
address now the one thing I have to be
aware of if is if I play Bishop takes H3
white can try to move Knight
H4 but in this case I think Knight H4
I'll just keep my queen on the G
file keep the pin attack the
Knight
and there's not too many other ways to
deal with the checkmating
threat it would be nice if we see Knight
G3 Knight G3 I could take because F Pawn
is
pinned but in this case yeah let's go
ahead
and attack the
Knight think Queen G5 or queen G4 were
pretty
similar now the problem for white is a
knight's attacked white would like like
to play G3 but then I take the
Rook it doesn't seem like there's a
great way
to defend everything in White's
position I am realizing like maybe I
could have taken the pawn at some point
in the
opening there's so many lines where
white will gabit Eon or it can be
dangerous to
take definitely go back and
analyze the other thing I wanted to
mention is when I played Queen G6 like
Not only was i setting up Bishop takes
H3 but there's also ideas of
F5 which can be very nice in these sort
of positions and similar to last game
like once you're castled then moving the
F Pawn can be a nice way of expanding
and
attacking oh my opponent
disconnected AO resign about to
[Music]
happen yeah sometimes this will happen
in uh in the speedrun not sure if it's a
a rage quit or an internet
issue but okay game is over after 16
moves and again we see
from very like kind of safe opening from
both of
us white just kind of
self-destructed starting with B4 like
just I think not realizing that I could
take the pawn for
free and then and I've noticed this uh
this is a common mistake too like when
when people bring out their Bishops to
pin the
Knight it's usually not good to take the
Knight unless like there's some very
clear reason for it cuz here it just
helped get the queen
involved so going back yeah could I
actually have taken the pawn on
e4 so in this position when white played
H3
I should have definitely spent some time
considering it because yeah usually
white will play D3 or Knight C3 or Rook
E1
first um of course the drawback with
taking the pawn
is like white can probably get some
counterplay although Rook E1 blunders
Bishop takes
F2 I'm checking with engine now just
curious oh wow so the engine is saying
the best move for white is to play
Knight
C3 wow and it could have been like a
Stafford Gambit like takes
takes and white has like pretty good
compensation here cuz this is a threat
maybe even this and this is a threat I
mean evalar says it's about
[Music]
equal but I think it's a a more exciting
position to play for
white but there are situations like
early in the game where you you should
at least consider taking the pawn and I
I should have taken more time to realize
the pawn was hanging there but maybe
this is something to keep in mind for
the future like play H3 allow this and
then reverse Stafford Gambit that isn't
losing for
whites I wonder if any of the times I
got utterly crushed by people at my
rating it was really someone like Rosen
climbing a new
account yeah I do want to uh clarify
that any speedrun account will have this
tag it will say authorized speedrun
account and all my opponents will have
their ratings
refunded so there's not too many people
who have authorized speedrun accounts on
chess.com
anyway uh let's move on to another game
playing Paul M
money and maybe we'll have a a similar
opening
oh we have a
Spanish so against a Spanish I like to
play
A6 Bishop A4 is the most common
move and uh then Knight F6
actually I'm debating here cuz Knight F6
is like the main main
line I think I I'll play the first
opening I learned against the Spanish I
I have my profile picture it's a picture
of me when I was like 9 or 10 years
old and this is called the steinet
defense and there's some ideas here
where um like there's some cool traps if
White's not
careful but after
castling after castling I'll play KN
F6 it's been many years since I last
played this uh defense for
black of course the drawback is my
Bishop can't develop as
actively but I can still play Bishop
E7 and if my opponent doesn't fall for
the main trap in this opening then I'll
share it after the game main trap
usually starts with white playing D4
early a D3 very solid move well
Castle
and then okay Pawn
C3 so we're having kind of a
more know what we call this like more
closed Spanish type
position and there are a few ideas going
forward from
here like there's a move here
which I remember when I was younger this
sort of move would never cross my
mind but I think it's one of the more
solid ways to play this
position and to understand the move I
guess I'll explain that this Knight no
longer really serves a purpose on C6
like it's just restricted by White's
pawn and it would much
rather be on a
square like
G6 um but to get there it can take a
while
so and even before G6 it would much
rather be on square like
D7 cuz I want to Fe C to the bishop and
have the bishop um along the long
diagonal so the move I'm going to play
is Knight
B8 which generally it's like not advised
to put your pieces back on their
starting squares out of the
opening but in this case yeah I just
want to get the Knight to D7 put the
bishop on B7 and then later I can do
this maneuver like Rook E8 Knight f8 and
Knight
G6 and it's not easy for white to like
punish me for
this I think the general principle is
when I'm going to play Knight D7
reinforce the pawn like when the
position is more closed then you have a
bit more time to maneuver your
pieces but D4 is probably the most um
most principled approach like trying
trying to challenge the
center my pawn and Knight are necessary
in reinforcing
E5 okay let's play Bishop
B7 with Queen D3 white is creating the
battery thankfully there's a pawn in the
way okay
opponent pressuring the Knight I don't
think I mind like if Bishop takes Knight
I'll take back with my Bishop so I'll go
for
H6 yeah second game in a row we see
opponent Play Bishop G5 and very early
Bishop takes
F6 uh here I do have to be careful
though debating whether to take with
Pawn I mean Pawn Knight or Bishop are
all possible I don't want to take with
Bishop because and I have the bishop
pair
now taking with Knight
looks
nice and yeah if I take with Bishop then
white has the possibility of maybe even
playing F4 and then if I take there's E5
and White's threatening
checkmates so going to take some time
here and taking with
Pawn I think is a safer option although
then then The Bishop's not super
happy but if I take with Pawn maybe the
bishop can
maneuver to a happier
place and the drawback of taking with
Bishop like even if white doesn't play
F4 which I don't know if that's even
like so good like white could play this
and then this and then The Bishop's just
a Target in the center and white has
more
space so taking with Pawn then space is
pretty balanced here we both have pawns
facing each
other I'm also fixing this Pawn on e4 so
it's very hard for this bishop to find
life on that
diagonal Queen E3 is a sensible
move Queen
E3 let's improve the bishop and kick the
queen
in doing so I'm also kind of controlling
D2 so it's going to be hard for the
Knight to develop there so
[Music]
soon and White's playing a very solid
game so far I think there's just been
some
minor I think the the biggest mistake
from White was kind of a minor
positional mistake of Bishop takes
Knight of okay now I think we have the
the first major
mistake of just giving the pawn now I
can choose whether to take with Pawn or
bishop and taking with Bishop looks
nicer now the bishop is a very strong
piece now F5 comes to mind but I don't
want want to give the bishop a purpose
from C2 I also don't want to weaken this
diagonal
so and I think the strategy here is to
get the Rooks involved there's one fully
open
[Music]
file so I'll go for Queen
D6 not only setting up maybe some some
checks but also preparing Rook
d8 while he plays Knight
A3
my opponent's managing their time much
better than
me but I like the position okay Rook
D1 go for Queen
B6 deliver the
check now our Rooks have a staring
contest and it's a situation I don't
really want to take immediately and
concede the
[Music]
file so what to
do this is a position to ask like what
is my worst place piece and how do I
improve it I think the worst place piece
is a
bishop he was staring into a pawn that's
so well
defended and on C8 I mean it's another
Case by moving the moving a minor piece
back to its starting Square I think now
there's going to be ideas of Bishop G4
like Queen G6 and Bishop G4 would be a
nice
setup can't do that right away have to
save this
bishop but even Bishop E6 like have it
more
centralized have to move back
again I mean white has some initiative
like Bishop B3 would pressure f
s me my plan is still to play Queen
G6 that's a great Square for the queen
defending but also potentially attacking
gu I do have to watch out for
H5 H5 there's Queen
F6 after the game I'll I'll do my best
to answer questions from
chat
ooh okay so Rook
D1 I really want to play this but then
white can take with
check still may be
[Music]
playable another idea is to just block
the
[Music]
file I am walking into a
pin but I'm preventing The Rook trade
and threatening Bishop G4
which the opponent
allows So the plan has has paid
off and White's not really in time to
even win the pawn cuz I'll take the rook
and then then either play B4 or
takes yeah I do have to watch my time
though just over 3 minutes a nice thing
is once I take the
Rook then I think it's going to be very
easy for White's position to
crumble could potentially take the
Knight and now this Pawn is hanging yeah
white probably should have taken with
the bishop on
D1 I'm not scared of
C5 going to say if C5 I have Bishop E7
but there's also the
idea of
checkmating um now I think a lot of
people would maybe just take the pawn
with check but this position is actually
forced Checkmate in three
moves that's a nice mating pattern
forcing the king to
G1 and then Bishop C5
will eventually be
M Queen D4 is the only legal
move so a little bit of time to spare
I mean based on the way my opponent
played this game they I'd say they're
definitely
underrated like really no major mistakes
until
f4 on move
17 hopefully we don't see another like
Rage Quit
disconnect that might be the case though
okay there we
go so I did see some questions in chat
from
earlier also before I forget I do want
to show like the main opening trap like
when you play
D6 there's a really nice trap here it's
called the Noz Arc trap and there's a
lot of players who will just stumble
into it thinking that D4 looks like a
really nice move for
white um of course cuz yeah the knight's
pinned and if like takes takes then
white has pressure against the pinned
Knight
uh but D4 is like the first move that
could eventually walk into the
Trap because black has B5 here and after
Bishop to
B3 there's a really nice sequence
starting with takes takes
takes and then once white takes back
still looks good for white on the
surface but this position is black to
move and win
material kn first learned this as a kid
and then got so many people with this
over the
years good job sh the one person saying
C5 now when you play C5 or when you're
like considering playing
C5 it's good to see that you're
attacking the queen and you're
threatening to trap the bishop and play
C4 but it's actually a little bit more
complicated because white has will move
Queen
D5
and at first it looks like black is
losing
material because okay made his threat
The Rook is threatened if you play C4
you lose the rook and it's it's not good
for
black so in order to play C5 you have to
know what to do
next yeah good job the same person
saying Bishop E6 defending F7 and
A8 but then white plays Queen C6
and from here black can block the check
with the
bishop and when the queen moves back now
white only has one threat because the
rook's
defended and um yeah rather than playing
Bishop E6 back and maybe going for a
draw black can play
C4 preventing the May threat trapping
the
bishop I've probably had this position
at least a dozen times over at least
over my early chess
career and then sometimes white will
like take take take and then castle and
then blunder more material with Bishop
B5 so it can snowball downwards pretty
quickly for
white but anyway this is um it's a very
solid and also tricky approach to
playing the Spanish I mean my opponent
didn't fall for the Trap and then we got
we got an inter interesting battle into
the middle
game um I know Knight B8 Knight B8 is a
very highle move maybe it's not the best
move there's a different variation in
the Spanish called the
Brier which usually starts with Knight
B8 in a similar
position and it's really just a matter
of getting the ideal setup for the
pieces there's a question about B4 at
some
point oh yeah um when white played
Knight A3 I wanted to keep the pawn on
B5 restricting the Knight although B4
maybe would be interesting cuz if Knight
here then Queen here could potentially
win
material but from a positional
standpoint I didn't really want to allow
the Knight to to
centralize all right I think I'll do one
more we'll have a longer episode a new
10minute game rated
938 playing Hal
E7 and we have a
sicilian so against the Sicilian I'm
going to play an
approach I don't think I've played yet
in the
speedrun uh the most common approach is
to play open Sicilian with
D4 and then there's a lot of different
variations black can choose from but
there's another approach to play the
move C3 here which very simply prepares
Pawn
D4 I'm really just aiming to keep the
game on my turf also trying to build up
a big Center like when I play Pawn D4
then after takes takes already have two
Pawns in the center have pretty easy
development as
[Music]
well black playing Pawn
E6 Pawn E6 is
maybe an attempt to play this maybe also
attempting to play
D5 but it does beg the question like can
I can I be aggressive Here pawn
D5 attacking the
Knight there's cases where Pawn D5 can
be a bit overextending but I think in
this
case like D5 is supported by the pawn
Knight
queen I'm trying to open the position
with blackx King still in the center
so we we have a much different vibe this
game compared to the previous
game I mean as white I'm being a lot
more
aggressive getting initiative
early now the Knight has to choose where
to
go and Knight E5 is probably the most
interesting
try I mean I would love to take the
Knight and after Bishop takes play Queen
E2 but then black can play Queen E7 I
think it's okay there for
black I mean there is an idea to play
Pawn
D6 actually taking some time to consider
the options I would also really like to
Castle and just get my king
safe as soon as
possible yeah I think I'll take
once just because a bishop on E5 on E5
could be a Target going
forward and queen
E2 in assuming it doesn't win anything
tactically which I don't think it does
Queen E2 can be a positional mistake
because it blocks in my
Bishop so I'll start with the move
Bishop
B5 which ensures that when I play Queen
E2 I'm not bling blocking my Bishop
getting ready to Castle also pinning the
pawn so preventing Pawn
D6 I was thinking if black develops a
knight to prepare casting and then I'll
have Bishop
H6 but we see Pawn A6 that's a probably
a respectable move if I play this and
there's
B5 considering Queen E2
here Queen E2 Queen E7
[Music]
know I'll drop the bishop
back I'm allowing black to
expand I'll play Bishop
B3 I mean really I have two goals in
this
position the first goal is to Castle get
in rookie one and then secondly I want
to prevent black from
castling
uh yeah let's start with Bishop to
B3 so depending what black
does I'll try and accomplish my
goals yeah if I get the Rook to E1
that's much more powerful than having my
queen along the eile like Queen E2 Queen
E7 could potentially lead to an early
Queen trade which I don't really
want so that's
Castle I mean black could go super aggro
here like Queen
H4 then I have to choose between this
this or
this F4 is definitely the most
aggressive
move kind of like
F4 just forcing the bishop to
retreat and there's a pretty big benefit
like once the bishop does
retreat it's no longer going to be
defending
D6 and then I can strike with Knight
E4 and then rather than black focusing
on castling black will have to focus on
defending the
pawn
oo okay so the bishop trades off
so no more chance to play Knight
E4 um the benefit here though for white
is I have the two
Bishops but I also um I mean I'm most
happy about having the dark Square
Bishop with black having a lot of dark
Square
weaknesses on the king
side and I'll start here with Queen D4 I
mean Rook E1 is also
[Music]
possible maybe I should take some
time and the problem with Rook E1 is
let's say King f8 then my queen is tied
down to the Rook I really would like the
queen to come to the
center yeah let's start with Queen
D4 I'm not only pinning the Knight but
I'm setting up a tactic here if Black's
not careful in
castles then I was going to play
G3 now G3 would lose the
game but I might as well take the Rook
with check
first the thing is when I take the Rook
I have to make sure I have a followup I
think I can just play
H3 I'm not seeing how black can make
good
progress
it is kind of
risky like kind of abandoning my king
side but H3
should allow all the bases to be
covered and if I can just not get mated
and
not lose back material I should be good
up a full Rook
here Knights
attacked in a situation like this black
would really like to look for ways to
maybe expose the king and somehow get
Perpetual but it's just not easy to do
with a just a queen and the
Knight okay so that defends The Rook and
attacks the queen it does leave the
Knight
[Music]
hanging so I have a
choice between this and this
mainly I like Queen
G7 staying in Black's territory now
threatening the pawn still threatening
the
Knight Knight H6 would be a sad move for
back to play although maybe it's
necessary
and black would really like to get the
Rook like to
E2 I think it's a little bit too
slow speaking of too slow I do have to
watch my time as
well below 5 minutes but things are
under
control so knight6 does defend maybe
also prepares this but no the knight's
tied down to the
pawn
so question what to do next considering
this move unleashing the
bishop and then if Knight takes I take
the pawn force a king
back yeah that looks pretty
good like F5 aims to open the bishop and
The
Rook there's really not much counter
playay for black
here
and once the King goes back then The
Rook can't really get in oh but the
Knight goes
back okay so it looks good but still
takes a little bit of work think I'll
start with Queen
E6 just optimizing the queen maybe
preparing The Rook to come
in and here yeah I think here it's just
a matter of adding more pieces to the
attack and there's nice
[Music]
move is are a nice move I was about to
blunder my
Bishop Bishop here Queen takes and uh I
just want to get the Rook to
E1 so maybe bishop F4 is simplest
like threatening the
pawn rather than taking the pawn with
the queen immediately if I can take with
Bishop next then it's going to be
[Music]
overwhelming I think a lot of the
stemmed from black like not being able
to Castle early even stemmed from like
D5 so early
on never loosening the
grip so the queen does defend from a
distance I'm very very close to
Checkmate
here I mean generally in these positions
you want to consider the Chucks and the
forcing
moves but I think the the simple
approach just Rook
E1 like everything's cover the queen and
Bishop defend any shenanigans
and now there's three attackers against
a knight yeah after this game I can show
how my opponent could have
improved I played an opening which
probably isn't the most common at this
[Music]
level opponent threatening maate in one
good
try but I'm threatening mate in I'm just
mating in
like one or two more
moves yeah no need need to take the
Rook Rook f8 will be
checkmates so yeah let's try and uh
provide some lessons for the black
player I am assuming that like if I had
played D4 then my opponent probably
would have been happy to go into what's
called The Accelerated dragon
this is a very um very nice opening like
also very kind of beginner friendly
opening black aims to exert pressure in
the center and develop actively
sometimes gets in D5
quickly but when white plays
C3 so early like usually if white plays
C3 on move two or in this case on move
three black should react a bit
differently uh cuz when black plays G6 I
was very happy to uh just control the
space and we saw how that transformed
into a much bigger
Advantage
so like if you're playing Black here
there's generally
two two mainstream
moves uh one is Knight F6 which simply
aims to Counterattack the pawn and then
it usually provokes E5 and then Knight
D5 then D4 and then this this is a whole
like rabbit hole of theory uh takes
takes
D6 but black can uh can get by with
this um but there's another move here
which is usually my choice is to play
Pawn
D5 and this resembles kind of a delayed
scan Navien but the point is after takes
takes black is kind of taking advantage
of the fact that there's no Knight C3 so
the pawn is taking away the Square from
the Knight
and even if white plays D4 then black
can usually leave the queen here and
just develop in a more active
man so I guess for anyone that plays
cecilian if your opponent plays C3 early
you should keep in mind this move
D5 it can lead to um just more pleasant
positions to play for
black so I think that's going to be the
last game of this
episode if you're watching in in the
future on YouTube say goodbye to Twitch
chat if you're watching live on
Twitch uh say hi or bye to the Future
YouTube
audience also stay tuned for the next
episode where I'll probably hopefully
make my run towards 1,000
ELO okay got some twitch shatters
here yeah
goodbye